buildings all over Mexico City are in
ruins this morning after a 7.1 magnitude
earthquake the violent shaking yesterday
created widespread destruction at least
217 people have been confirmed dead so
far rescuers duct through collapsed
buildings all night pulling out
survivors the quake was centered about
70 miles southeast of Mexico City in the
state of webblock this is the second
deadly earthquake to hit Mexico this
month an eight point one quake killed at
least 90 people in southern Mexico two
weeks ago and well the forecast is in
Mexico City with the desperate search
for those missing men well good morning
good morning right now every second is
critical in neighborhoods like this one
I want you to take a look behind me that
is what's left of a six-story office
building that collapsed we are told that
20 people have been rescued but up to 40
people may still be trapped inside
search and rescue operations like this
one are happening throughout the Mexican
Capitol this morning
as soon as the earthquake hit parts of
central Mexico were devastated building
after building crumbled to the ground
leaving massive piles of splintered wood
and broken concrete at least 25 students
and teachers were killed when an
elementary school collapsed in Mexico
City all but four of them were children
Mexican president Enrique Pena Nieto
visited the wreckage last night where
rescuers were digging for the missing US
citizen Brittany Kaiser was giving a
presentation in Mexico City when it
struck she and thousands of people fled
to the streets as the air filled with
smoke from collapsed buildings she came
outside you can see everything moving
from street lamps and the trees and like
anything even like the cars that were on
the street there are some buildings are
completely and utterly demolished rescue
teams and volunteers searched through
the rubble for victims they found
several people trapped and lifted them
to safety on stretchers
there was one hard jolt and then the
ground began to roll the deadly
earthquake happened exactly 32 years
after the 1985 Mexico quake that killed
thousands orlando silver was in Mexico
City for both I mean the city is in
complete chaos and it just looked like
the city had been just one part it was
pretty devastating what you're seeing
now are the relatives of those who are
missing gathered here looking at a list
of names and hoping to see that their
loved ones may have been taken to a
hospital mexico's president is urging
calm after the earthquake saying the
priority is still search and rescue and
getting people medical attention but
that could take a long time there are up
to 44 buildings in the city that have
collapsed gale and unfortunately looking
at those pictures you know there will be
more loss of life but there's always a
miracle - thank you very what very much
Manuel Bojorquez reporting from Mexico
City